par exemple à dijon pour le moment donné
à peu près 700 un peu plus de 700000
euros de dépenses on peut estimer de
l'ordre de 1 million d'euros lequel des
deux françois rebsamen faut-il croire
sept cent mille ou un million d'euros
ces deux hommes reviennent régulièrement
dans la presse ces dernières semaines
aujourd'hui dijon est d'ailleurs apparu
au classement des cinq villes les plus
touchés financièrement mais il n'ya
qu'un montant qui reste le même à chaque
annonce celui de 250000 euros
il correspond aux dégradations du
mobilier urbain dans la facture il y a
aussi les indemnisations aux commerçants
les heures supplémentaires des agents
municipaux ou encore les exonérations
des terrasses du centre ville mais la
difficile d'avoir les sommes exactes
seules nos confrères de cette radio ont
pu avoir une liste détaillée
il faut enlever tous les déchets sur la
voie publique pour éviter qu'ils aient
trop de containers d'equihen containers
ayez mis le feu donc tout ça nous amène
à un total encore de l'ordre de 350
mille euros des puits il y a les manques
à gagner tous les samedis si l'on s'en
tient donc aux chiffres annoncés sur
cette radio locale l'addition correspond
à 250 milles euros de mobilier urbain
plus 150000 euros de gel de droit
terrasse plus 350000 euros d'heures
supplémentaires concernant les agents de
police et les agents de propreté et
enfin 220000 euros pour le manque à
gagner dans les transports on est à 970
mille euros
contacté par téléphone les commerçants
un syndicat de la mairie et l'union des
hôteliers sont formels on entend la
ville de dijon a bien pris des mesures
exceptionnelles
en revanche aucune somme nette annoncée
n'est pas une aide directe aux
commerçants chez soi des facilités donc
de stationnement pour les consommateurs
est fait d'un autre côté des gels de
droite terrasse donc là je n'ai pas fait
chiffres l'amour l'art devants en fin de
journée on a quand même fini par obtenir
cette information
un mail lapidaire de la mairie de dijon
qui confirme que l'estimation à 700000
euros pourrait atteindre un million
d'euros mais qui se refuse encore à nous
communiquer le détail de la facture
poste par poste